on ne peut dénationaliser immédiatement
deux des trois chaînes publiques de
télévision monsieur jacques chirac ayant
ainsi précisé ses souhaits en matière
d'audiovisuel en cas de victoire de la
droite
les 16 mars françois léotard lui a
répliqué très sèchement aujourd'hui il
ne faut pas faire trois pas en avant et
deux pas en arrière pour leurs soins de
la une de la 2e ou de l'a3 on en est au
numéro 5
les téléspectateurs belges seront bien
tranquille ils ne pourront l'a capté
pour l'instant
pour ses débuts d'une première chaîne de
télévision privée non codées bien nous
nous avons choisi de rester dans le
secteur qui est nôtre l'information est
également là uc retrace les quatorze
mois de l'enfantement difficile de la
cinquième marathon forcené des
personnages impitoyable un scénario où
tous les coups sont permis tel est le
feuilleton de la création de la sag coup
d'envoi l'an dernier françois mitterrand
fait le choix de la liberté l'espace
audiovisuel doit s'ouvrir
il faut donc se soient libres et il faut
qu'il y ait comme tout les gars c'est
d'ailleurs une réglementation une
organisation qui fasse que la liberté ne
tue pas la liberté
on réfléchit donc et cinq mois plus tard
le rapport brda conclu il y à la place
en france pour deux chaînes de plus
commercial
mais il faut être prudent nous avons
voulu que le paysage audiovisuel se
transforme en catastrophe
deux mois plus tard le conseil des
ministres fixe une date d'échéance des
bus 86
il y aura deux nouvelles chaînes privées
en france une généraliste l'a5 une
musicale la crise et des chaînes locales
dès lors on accélère le mouvement un
projet de loi est en discussion au
parlement qu'il adopte en y ajoutant un
amendement l'amendement tour eiffel la
bataille pour le droit d'installer des
émetteurs au sommet de la tour eiffel
commence
mais coup de théâtre on attendait la clt
groupe luxembourgeois et c'est le groupe
seydoux vers l'estonie riboud qui signe
le 20 novembre et emporte contrat de
l'a5
il reste trois mois trois mois d'une
bataille féroce
principale cible silvio berlusconi les
créateurs les cinéastes crie au massacre
culturel
c'est comme si on avait voulu [ __ ] en
l'air tout ce qui avait été entrepris
par jacques lang depuis quatre ans je
vous souhaite une belle réussite
un gouvernement de droite qui serait pas
arrivé à faire ça la clt écarté déposent
un recours devant le conseil d'état et
la haute autorité dénoncent les
privilèges accordés à la saq menaçant la
création nous sommes le 16 janvier
néanmoins le vin les promoteurs de la
cinquième chaîne présente officiellement
leur programme
il reste juste un mois le 11 février les
derniers essais techniques sont
concluants
ce soir-là 5 peut démarrer à la date
prévue
mais il vous faudra attendre encore
quelques temps pour suivre le prochain
épisode
en effet l'opposition si elle en fort à
l'attention de tout reprendre à zéro